do you foresee the possibility of
alternative social media outlets sort of
viewing all the issues that people do
have with Google or Facebook or Twitter
and any of these are perceived to be
biased sources of information and coming
up with something that has clear
protections in there sort of like the
founding fathers did when they'd
established our system of government
that you listen we don't want that let's
let's organize that as we're starting to
make sure that this doesn't doesn't ever
turn into some sort of an echo chamber
yeah look I am it's way above my pay
grade yeah but what I know gets us there
is competition I know that the only
thing that has ever gotten us to the
next great innovation is the enforcement
of competition which is why it's a
problem when someone like Facebook
absolutely buys in so what gave us the
internet yeah was interventions by the
government against AT&T which was the
dominant telecommunications company for
more than a century that finally said
enough of this you can't leverage your
power to control all innovation and once
that intervention happened people could
layer on top of their wires a new
network called the Internet yeah and
when they did that government said to
companies like cable television
companies okay yeah you've got broadband
across your cable line but that doesn't
mean you get to decide what applications
go on that cable line so you your HP I
mean your the cable company you can't
say that there can't be Netflix on the
cable or you can't slow netflix down no
obviously they would want a slow
nitpicks down because Netflix is a
competitor with their basic business
model but the intervention to assure
competition created the opportunity for
these great new innovations no nobody at
the beginning of that had any clue about
what would come out of it all that they
knew was that the only way to get
something new and great was to assure
competition and that's the commitment
we've given up since 2000 since George
Bush became president 2001
there's been no major enforcement action
by the antitrust department against any
of these companies and that is a huge
problem and until we rediscover the
importance of competition
not because we're geniuses and we can
figure out what the future will bring
but because we know from the past that
the only way the future comes is if you
guarantee competition unless we do that
we're never gonna solve any of these
problems
yeah ensuring competition is ensuring
innovations ensuring and anybody who
doesn't want competition wants to stifle
innovation and it's got to be thought to
be a selfish proposition right and the
basic is so you know the basic argument
in competition law you know there's
competition law got taken over by a
bunch of Chicago economists who said the
only question was efficiency or a
consumer welfare but there's another
perspective that libertarians like Luigi
Zingales who's a an economist that you
know Chicago Business School and and
people who are not libertarians like Tim
Wu who's a professor at Columbia embrace
and this is the idea of political
antitrust and the idea of political
antitrust is you should also worry if
companies are so big that they can
corrupt the government like this is a
dimension to worry about too because if
they get to be so big that they can
corrupt the government then you know
that they will use that power to protect
themselves against innovation because if
an innovator comes he doesn't come with
50 lobbyists he just comes with a great
idea mmm I mean you know Elon Musk saw
this dramatically as he's developing
this incredible alternative and tried to
figure out how to sell it inside of
states and then the lobbyists for the
car companies would go state-by-state
and forbid them from being able to sell
cars without a local dealership in the
state right there was a huge fight as
the incumbent industries leveraged their
power over government to protect
themselves from this new competitor and
this is the this is the fight we have to
we have to make central again because if
we don't do that then the dinosaurs will
have the power through this corrupted
political system to protect themselves
against the future and this is just the
moment when we need to figure out how to
make the future come